et je joins maintenant à Dublin
l'archéologue subaquatique et ex chef du
service d'archéologie subaquatique de
parc Canada Marc-André Bernier monsieur
Bernier bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur Bernier c'est vraiment
une très vaste opération de recherche là
qui est en cours c'est un peu comme
chercher une aiguille dans une boîte de
foin non
oui c'est vraiment chercher chercher
une goutte d'eau dans l'océan presque
mais en fait on a un bon point de départ
par contre parce que on connaît bon on
connaissait la destination de de
sous-marin on savait que on sait que ils
étaient presque rendus à l'épreuve
relativement parlant parce que c'est une
descente de deux heures et ça faisait
plus d'une heure et demie qu'ils étaient
en décembre donc ça nous donne déjà
quand même un point de départ c'est pas
comme quand on cherchait par exemple les
débris de l'avion de ma région Airlines
qui s'est écrasé dans le Pacifique et là
c'était vraiment une recherche là on a
un bon point de départ et il s'agit
maintenant de d'essayer de maximiser les
efforts de recherche vous connaissez
bien ce site du Titanic parce que pour
le moment on est tout à fait sans
nouvelles donc c'est une exploration
quoi qui demande qui qui présente
beaucoup de risques
évidemment beaucoup de risques c'est à
3800 mètres de profondeur donc c'est
c'est
une exploit technologique de pouvoir
atteindre l'effet de recherche dans ces
profondeurs là par contre c'est
plusieurs expéditions sur le Titanic
depuis la découverte
les premières les premières décembre
avec habiter en 1987 donc on a on a il y
a de l'expérience ce sous-marin là qui
était qui est en difficulté avait déjà
fait deux campagnes déjà de descendre
donc
ce sont des plongés
qu'on a fait plus de rapport
régulièrement mais qui qui ont eu lieu
dans le passé et donc c'est pour ça un
peu que bon ces expéditions là on prend
ça pour acquis comme c'est un bon on va
voir le Titanic mais c'est pas simple et
là on en a la preuve à quel point c'est
un environnement difficile justement
pour ce genre de recherche
pour avoir suivi les travaux de
cartographie qui a eu lieu par les
Américains de
des parcs nationaux américains et de
neurones il y a une dizaine d'années
donc c'est bon les tendu en deux
morceaux qui sont assez distantes de
l'autre et donc bon évidemment on avait
un plan de plongée on sait vers quelle
épave on se dirige quelle partie on se
dirigeait sinon c'est sur un fond assez
plat assez dénudé et donc il y a un
champ de débris autour des épaves le
problème c'est c'est l'épave elle-même
c'est-à-dire que c'est une épave très
grande et donc si on a si jamais le
sous-marin était tombé sur les pavs à ce
moment-là
ça serait plus difficile à détecter
peut-être un peu mais il y a évidemment
des débris beaucoup de métal sur lequel
on peut s'accrocher et donc ça ça va
compliquer les recherches aussi surtout
si on descend avec un robot il faut
absolument éviter de que l'on câble
s'attache ou s'accroche à l'époque c'est
ça la grande difficulté outre ça
visibilité nulle évidemment il faut
avoir évidemment des sous-mains de bonne
lumière mais c'est quand même un champ
de vision restreint donc il faut
toujours faire attention de se déplacer
parce qu'on voit pas on n'a pas une très
très bonne périphérie pour la vision
alors on se
pose tout de travailler
ainsi va loin d'une balise de détresse
oui évidemment ça c'est ce qu'on va on
va chercher à
sonder
de la surface ou même du rouv on va
sonder pour essayer de capter tout tout
tous les sons qui pourraient nous
indiquer une direction mais aussi des
indiquer qu'il y a des survivants à bord
du sous-marin donc ça c'est évidemment
une autre une autre une autre élément
qui peut aider à localiser cette partie
parce que la première étape c'est
vraiment de trouver où est ce sous-marin
là c'est souvent le sous-marin une fois
qu'il aurait été repéré là ça sera un
autre problème pour essayer de le
remonter ou de
d'après les
occupants mais la première étape ne peut
pas arriver à
l'opération de sauvetage sans savoir si
il est au fond aussi les temps surface
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on balaye qu'on
fait des recherches en avion pour
essayer de voir si on est capable de si
jamais il est remonter et il est à la
dérive de pouvoir le dériver mais la
première étape c'est vraiment localiser
le sous-marin autour de l'épargne
possible mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a pu se
passer selon vous quels sont les
scénarios possibles
un expert en sous-marin mais évidemment
on peut penser qu'il y a eu les la
communication a été coupée à ce
moment-là on pense tout de suite à des
problèmes mécaniques problèmes de
batterie
problème électrique donc vraiment
ce serait vraiment une des anomalies
techniques si il y avait il était déjà
aux femmes on pourrait penser peut-être
à s'accrocher sur les pages des
problèmes comme ça mais à ce moment ici
c'est difficile de savoir et c'est pour
ça aussi que évidemment on n'a pas trop
de détails parce que on est dans
l'inconnu mais c'est possiblement des
briques techniques plus le temps passe
on peut se dire qu'ils ont peut-être
heurté un objet sur le fond marin il y a
toutes sortes de possibilités en fait et
c'est très difficile avec à cette
distance à cette profondeur là de
l'océan
extrêmement difficile on est à
3800 mètres donc on a une pression de
380 atmosphères ou bar donc on travaille
dans les milieux extrêmes c'est comme
aller dans l'espace et
dans une certaine mesure on peut
comparer ça aller dans l'espace on n'est
pas dans notre environnement c'est c'est
une exploré une nouvelle frontière dans
les fonds marins on en connaît très peu
mais dans ce cas ici c'est un endroit
qui est bien connu qui était
cartographié donc ça ça donne un
avantage aux recherches donc à ce
point-ci le temps à pas le temps passe
évidemment mais est-ce qu'il y a encore
de l'espoir selon vous de les retrouver
vivant
il y a toujours l'espoir faut garder de
l'espoir je pense que si parce qu'on
connaît pas les détails de l'incident
mais si vraiment
il y a un brimécanique et le sous-marin
est dans le fond à ce moment-là il y a
de l'espoir qui soit lion assez
d'oxygène une techniquement pour pour
continuer
le problème c'est que le temps commence
à manquer et donc les efforts de
recherche évidemment s'accélèrent mais
il faut garder espoir on a eu des
surprises dernièrement avec des
sauvetages des jeunes qu'on a bien dans
la jungle ou
les
coins après 40 jours donc c'est des
exemples de résilience qui nous font
garder espoir même si dans ce cas là on
parle vraiment de conditions extrêmes
comme vous l'avez dit
exactement merci beaucoup monsieur
Bernier de toutes ces indications merci
ça me fait plaisir merci